i understand that this 25 year old
suspect is a british citizen
with somali heritage it's not yet clear
if he also holds dual somali citizenship
but clearly the police and security
services are going to be pouring over
this individual
trying to work out um whether they he
was on their radar or not
whether they knew anything about him
and and what potentially drove him
potentially to to commit any sort of
attack he's obviously he's he's been
arrested and clearly there are um a lot
of questions still unanswered and i'm
sure that police will provide updates we
know that counterterrorism police now
involved in this investigation a major
investigation and like you say
one that has caused
significant alarm and concern amongst
all mps amongst the whole country and
also that news too
from the home secretary spokesman saying
that pretty patel
has asked for
police forces to conduct a review of the
security arrangements for mps
immediately
and to report back in due course again a
sign of how
this attack on the back of previous
attacks is really raising concern about
the protection required for mps to keep
them safe so they can do their job